[A] For the ecosystem builders out there,
[A] I think the way that you guys do things is quite novel.
[A] Can you speak through your process a little bit?
[A] Like how you build it,
[A] how you're architecting this ecosystem moving forward?
[B] We take definitely a credibly neutral approach
[B] that a lot of other ecosystems disagree with.
[B] Credibly neutral doesn't mean
[B] that we give every single team the same amount of resources
[B] because that doesn't make sense.
[B] But what we do is we double down
[B] on the teams that are able to show
[B] user retention and traction themselves
[B] because that's actually where
[B] the resources and the attention will go the furthest.
[B] But actually making it like a level playing ground
[B] for everyone to get to that stage,
[B] I would say that's kind of like the core thesis.